ça s'appelle t au texte après deux ans
de travaux et l'apport de 37 entreprises
partenaires l'homme d'affaires alexandre
taillefer lens en grande pompe son bébé
voici donc la première flotte de taxis
électriques théo tout des voitures
blanches et vertes
dennis en lift des kia soul et quelques
tesla une cinquantaine de ces taxis
ferro des tests dans les rues de
montréal à partir du 26 novembre et les
téoz seront disponibles au grand public
en mars
on y va on s'en va la chambre de
commerce petit tour à bord avec
alexandre taillefer
il promet que les montréalais aimeront
leur expérience en taxis électriques des
chauffeurs qui ont passé les processus
d'entrevue exhaustif qui partage la
vision qu'on a un service wi fi à
lesterps de la voiture capacité de
recharger le téléphone des tablettes à
l'arrière le paiement automatisé
l'application mobile le projet nécessite
des investissements de 250 millions de
dollars
l'homme d'affaires croit que ce sera un
succès il garantit à ses chauffeurs
caisse de l'art leur une vision qui me
permet de réduire les coûts d'opération
parce qu'on utilise d'électricité au
lieu de l'énergie fossile mais également
de réduire les coûts d'opération parce
que on gère de façon beaucoup plus
intelligente à cause d'utilisation de la
technologie
l'offre et la demande notre objectif est
de lancer sans taxi par mois à partir de
juin 2010 est pour que d'ici 2019 la
moitié de la flotte montréalaise soit
électrifié ça donc deux mille deux mille
2000 à 2250 taxi les prix seront les
mêmes que ceux des taxis mais l'été
offriront des forfaits spéciaux par
exemple on pourrait garantir un tarif
maximal pour une course qu'on pourrait
traduire par un aller-retour à dorval
pour 65 da au lieu de 85 90 dollars
actuellement pratiqués l'industrie du
taxi est contente
ma plus grande réjouissance aujourd'hui
c'est de voir qu'il veut oeuvrer à
l'intérieur des règles du jeu des lois
et des règlements du québec
contrairement à ce qu'on connaît depuis
quelques mois une allusion à l'ennemi
numéro 1 des taxis hubert alexandre
taillefer va d'ailleurs jusqu'à prévoir
la mort d'hubert à montréal d'ici cinq
ans ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio
canada montréal